well
let's
set this up
real quick
and talk
into the [ __ ] camera
what's going on everybody um
these are vlogs these are just
conversation vlogs yeah i might be
traveling around here and there i might
be walking around with stuff and
doing things as these ideas just pop in
my head i'm just gonna talk about it and
these are like topics that probably i
brought up on the podcast here and there
but i i keep getting this reoccurring
question in my dms
non-stop and it's probably one of the
most
important yet very obnoxious things that
everybody [ __ ] asks and this is for
new content creators i am an older
content creator i'm not really old but
i've been on this space for a very very
long time so when you ask me about
content creation and what you should do
to create content it depends on the type
of content creator you want to be right
because there's fast content i.e tick
tock and instagram reels where you
basically just have to copy what
everybody else does and add your own
spin to it i'm not saying that in a
salty weird way i'm just saying it like
how it is because content creation is a
weird thing right because when you say
look how do i shoot dope videos well
definitively i don't know what dope
videos are right because the things that
get the most view it's usually on
instagram reels or fast content like
tick tock where you know you'll
say some [ __ ] that everybody else says
if you're an asian person just dress up
as an asian mom and make the same
[ __ ] asian jokes that everybody else
makes but seriously you just you know
dress up as your mom once every now and
then but try something new
yeah when it comes to this topic people
usually ask about equipment
well
equipment's such a weird thing right
because we
genuinely believe that the better
equipment that we have we can shoot
better videos yeah
it might look better the quality but
usually video content has nothing to do
with the camera in terms of like 90 of
what you create and i'll bring it back
to the fast content creators they're not
shooting on the best cameras but their
content is something that's very catchy
now if one of the things that you guys
are going to look back on is saying like
well i couldn't create videos because i
didn't have a nice enough camera that
just means you suck it means you haven't
written anything it means you don't have
any great ideas and you think that
buying new camera gear is going to make
you into a better creator and that's
just not true you
[ __ ] suck you know creating content
has a lot more to do with what you're
making versus what you're making it with
okay and listen to what i just said a
lot of you don't understand check this
out this here
is a video camera
most of you don't realize that this here
is an actual video camera when we first
started shooting video years ago we
didn't even have the technology that's
in this phone in the bigger cameras that
we had it didn't have slow-mo it didn't
have all these editing apps in it you
could shoot a majority of your content
on this phone
and most people wouldn't even realize
that it's shot on the phone in the first
place content creation has a lot to do
with more of what you're creating than
what you are shooting or creating it
with i know that we're in a generation
right now where a lot of people want to
tell you things that'll make you feel
better well not papa so you [ __ ] suck
you keep using your gear as an excuse as
to why you can't create content when you
have a [ __ ] 1300 phone
on you at all times it's pure [ __ ]
nonsense and in fact if you have a new
iphone it even has this weird thing
where it creates a depth of field so you
don't even have to switch out lenses
depending on how you use the phone so
what is really holding you back listen
when i first started in this space and
i've told the story a million times
before um i didn't have the support of
my parents
if anything else they wanted me to stay
in school i dropped out and i made scary
decisions i'm not telling you to live
your life the way that i did
but
i wanted to pursue something and that
fear is what
caused growth
like you don't grow without being in
these uncomfortable situations so if the
main reason why you are not creating
content is simply because you're waiting
to save money to buy better gear i
guarantee when you [ __ ] get that
camera you might as well be shooting on
a goddamn potato you suck you suck
because you haven't practiced you suck
because you're scared and you suck
because you haven't really thought about
creating content you're only thinking
about buying [ __ ] to create it but you
have nothing to shoot so
with all due respect if you want to
become a content creator just start
creating not everything you make is
going to be gold you know a majority of
the stuff when i look back at the things
that i shot i'm like this stuff isn't
that great it sucks compared to what i
can shoot now but if i waited and waited
for an opportunity to shoot things
simply based on my gear i wouldn't have
shot anything at all you're better than
that so for now what i'm saying is that
you suck for now
so
if you have a phone
you have anything to shoot with start
with that start with what you have and
then afterwards grow
you can do it my friends you're trash
now but guess what
crumple yourself recycle and you'll
become
sea waste
got it
really wanted me to do these videos see
y'all next time